hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
i am inside a property that i'm project
managing
we're turning this property from a
little three bed
house that we bought for 43 000 pounds
to
a nice beautiful hmo add value
refinance and it sounds so easy you know
when i say vrr
buy refurbish refinance rent that word
refurbished like
refurbish it's such an easy thing to say
but to do
it can be a little bit of a nightmare so
i thought i'd share behind the scenes
some of the problems and some of the
hardships that you have to face as a
as a project manager or as a developer
investor now this project
isn't mine i don't own this i'm project
managing it i sourced it on
to an investor and you know when you say
let's knock it not
let's knock it back to brick you know
you hear investors say oh he's knocking
back to brick
um what that means is literally knocking
back to brick
so that means that you take everything
out strip the wallpaper
strip the carpets and and that's what we
did at first you saw it on youtube we
stripped it all out
we got a skip we put all the ugly old
carpets the wallpaper
the bathroom where i'm standing right
now this was a bathroom
this was a bathroom it had a little
kitchen little bathroom and we just
opened it up why because we want to add
as much value as we can
and we thought actually if we can put
some ensuites upstairs
turn it into a hmo and have a big
kitchen it's going to be a much more
attractive house the kitchen is one of
the most important rooms in the house
so we knocked it back to brick and as
you can see
we literally did knock it back to brick
we needed another skip again
to get rid of all the junk because now
there's so much look at this
all this junk they need to go back to
the skip a lot of wood
a lot of bricks um now when you knock
something back to brick you've got two
options
okay you can either and
you're going to enjoy this right now
because you know when you walk into a
new house and it's beautiful
and you can see the walls and it's like
how did the walls get so
nice and clean and how did that happen
well when you knocked
it back to brick you've got two options
you can either i actually used to be a
plasterer
back in the day i used to plaster houses
so i worked on a building site so
i'm not gonna i'm not doing this work
myself okay it's very early in the
morning right now at 7 00 am
and the plasters are going to be coming
soon i've got i have not got builders
hands
now i make my money by negotiating deals
by making calls and i oversee builders
um
but but you've got two options you can
either base coat it which is a type of
plaster
which is like a thick brown plaster your
base coat it you'll put it on
and then once you've base coated it
you're then going to skim it
which is another type of plaster which
you get that really nice finish that
nice
shiny glass it's not actually glass but
it looks almost like glass
um so that's how you can do it that's
the old-school way of doing it
the easier way to do it is to just put
plasterboard over it so what we're doing
with this house is we're plastic
we're knocking it back to brick pretty
much not every room we're
plasterboarding it
and then we're going to skim over the
plasterboard
um i tell you what i don't miss i don't
miss plastering i'm much bigger than
what i do now
so this room kitchen now again there
have been problems
that have been delayed there have been
setbacks i mean one of the things that
we found
and you never know what problems you're
going to have exactly should always have
a contingency in place
but when we lifted up the carpets and
and the floorboards
the bricks under the house okay
so these bricks under the house were so
soggy and moist there was mold growing
on them
it was really really really not good and
and the builder said to me said look
we could just ignore it and try and put
the you know the joists on
but really we should probably change the
bricks i said what would happen
best case worst case like i guess what
would happen if we leave it if we leave
it
to be honest we're going to struggle to
even put the joists on these are the
joists
these hold the hold the floorboards up
he said we're going to struggle to even
put the joists in they're not sticking
to the bricks
he said the problem is if we do it and
we leave it and we leave these wet
moldy bricks into the house down the
line
the bricks could spread and he said then
the floorboards could fall in
now the thing is listen this house my
investor wants to keep this house
he's not doing it up to sell it he wants
to keep it so the last thing i want is
in six months time there to be problems
because the job's not being done
properly
need to do a job properly so we
literally
got rid of the bricks you can see these
bricks so these are
new bricks that we replaced with the old
soggy bricks
so now the joists have been put in
floorboards ready to go back on
and uh this is a problem that we didn't
anticipate and this takes time
you know doing things like this takes
time getting bricks moldy bricks removed
and
it's hard work i couldn't do it this
room one
again plaster we call this is plaster
you mix this put it in a bucket put
water in it mix it with a drill
and then you can skim it and at the
moment plastic is hard to get during the
pandemic while everyone was buying lots
of toilet paper
smart builders were buying lots of
plaster
so this is all ready now to have
plasterboard on and to be skimmed
which would be visually a big deal so
where the real world's taking place is
this part of the house
because this part of the house look you
can see
back to brick these bricks are okay
we're going to put plasterboard over
everything before plaster work
plasterball goes over everything though
when i saw this
when they joined us we're doing it i was
thinking is there really enough space
for three ensuites let me show you the
layout of what we're going with so
this room was a double room
now it's like a small double room come
in nice open entrance space
you've got a walk-in built-in not a walk
in a built-in wardrobe
which saves space which is really good
bed's probably going to go down here
you might get a one and a half times um
size bed so a small double
nice mirror beautiful room perfect
ensuite is going to be here
now the only thing is that i was
thinking before the plasterers
put all the plasterboard and start
skimming and making this absolutely set
i want to get the plumber out just to
confirm because to me this feels
on the small side you know to get a
shower a sink a toilet
the joiners have confirmed that this is
the size of a compact
ensuite but it just feels so small
um i just want to get a plumber out just
to confirm because you know i'm just
i don't want to finish the work and then
find out actually the problem is as well
if we go much more out if we come out
much more it's just going to reduce the
size of the room
and there's because it's a hmo the rooms
have to be a certain amount of
square footage this is all stuff that
needs to be overseen
also through here same story these
ensuites are the same size it just seems
on the small side but the idea is this
will be an off suite
now an off suite is an ensuite but it's
where it's not just on the bedroom so
it's off the bedroom
so this will be the ensuite or the off
suite of the
front bedroom and then this will be the
off suite of the
downstairs bedroom and again it's not
tiny this one's actually a little bigger
boiler's going to move downstairs
they're a little small so i just need to
make sure that everyone's all working
together
the plasterers the joiners everyone
everything's all happening right
so i don't think that's going to work i
do i think that's really really rubbish
if you do it that way
i think i thought that exactly i think
that each bedroom should have their own
ensuite because how rubbish is it
having to leave your room just to go
have a shower in there or use the
toilets
so it might be a bit more work maybe
cost a bit more
but you definitely will be able to have
an ensuite in each of the bedrooms and
have nice
three nice big bedrooms with the
ensuites um
it was i was so disappointed when i saw
the sizes of those ensuites
yeah big crap and then the rents for the
room as well you
get that much more anyway so i mean the
builder
could either get the drains to go out if
you put the plumbing in
or just get santa flow systems putting
into each bedroom
for the bathrooms yeah
[Music]
they're just going to be too small
so we're in conversations about the
possibility
of bringing ensuites forward
i'm genuinely a bit worried the
ensuite's up there it's
ain't gonna work pushed all to the back
of the house
to actually sit down to work everything
out and try and get everything
so usually it's possible yes so we don't
have to come back
for any alterations yeah i'm one of
these i like everything right if i
confess
i wasn't sure what david's plan i just
said today you know you need to get the
sweets in the [ __ ] yes
i have had so many conversations
back and forth with the plumbers the
project manager the builder on this
property
and we've you know what when i was
looking at the own suites last week
i was just thinking these ensuites are
too small
i mean maybe technically legally they're
okay
but they're going to really struggle to
rent and it was paining me
to have massive rooms at the front of
the house
with no ensuite where they had to walk
through to a tiny off suite where they
were all crammed into one corner of the
house
i just hated it so i was thinking about
it i was talking to my wife
i was talking to my brother
brainstorming and my wife said she goes
sami why don't you just put sani flo
toilets in i was like no no i don't want
to put sunny flows in by the way sunny
flow toilet
they're built differently but since ever
since i was 17 and i've worked on a
builder site
i was always told by the builders don't
put sunny flows in because they're a
pain
they make that noise when you flush them
for a few seconds after so i always
didn't want to go for sunday flows so
initially when we took on this project i
was like i don't want santa flows
however after investigating
now 12 years later this is why it's
important to keep up to date with common
knowledge
12 years later they have much better
sally flows than they used to have
so they have expensive sammy flows that
don't make the noise
and are much much better so we've
switched the plan
and now we're going to put sally flow
toilets in which means
we can have proper sized ensuites
which i'm over the moon about it's been
confirmed by the plumbers it's been
confirmed by all the team
so this has honestly changed everything
i'm so happy right now because before
this was a massive room
but imagine if you were a tenant living
in this room and you needed to go to the
toilet
in the middle of the night you'd have to
get changed and go upstairs
but now you can just slip into your
massive ensuite rather than getting
changed
up to your tiny off suite so this room
is going to be way more rentable
value is going to be pushed up i'm happy
let's go upstairs
and i'll show you the changes this room
here
the exact same story so this room
big room big bed lots and lots of space
now humongous ensuite
again same story it's gonna be shower
here big
shower toilet here is going to be a
stanley flow toilet
with a hand base in big in its own room
instead of this renting now for 350
this will probably rent out now for more
like closer to 400. that's what i've
been advised by the latin age
they were saying before oh the little
tony off suite
you might be getting 350 best case now
it will rent all day long
for more like 375 to 400 and then
this is the great thing okay because we
haven't got a cram
three toilets in this space
because it's just one ensuite not only
is it humongous
but because it's not shed shared this
corridor that was
this corridor is no longer a corridor
this corridor is now part of the room
which means that all this is a big room
we've got
here we've got wardrobe space
big big room humongous ensuite this
ensuite is so big
it'll be big enough to have a proper
bath in here and everything so
the floor plan has been changed now you
know what it's so easy
when you are a busy property investor to
just leave the floor plans to the team
and just go oh yeah whatever you think
is best you're the professionals but i
think it's really important as a
property investor
to actually be saying let me look at the
floor plans how can we creatively rejig
these floor plans
you know what's acceptable if i was
going to live here what would i want
and you want to be talking to your
letting agent you want to talk to the
estate agents to the valuers
the plumbers all the team using your
common sense in the middle of your power
team
and making the right call so that's what
we're doing i'm really happy
this project is taking a little bit
longer than i'd like to be honest and i
think there's lots of different reasons
for that
i mean there's so many annoying little
things that have happened but yesterday
we found there was a cat
under the floorboards so oh what are we
going to do the cat might die so we had
to
get really find the cat open up the
floorboards take it out
there's also been some problems with the
electrics so the electrics of um
we were gonna just fix the electrics but
it was costing more money we're finding
more and more problems
there was things that we were finding
like these old connectors
which are just absolutely important this
is this is not cool this is
this is not cool so we decided that
we're just going to rewire the entire
house
which is going to mean that once we have
finished the property it's complete
we won't need to do anything for the
electrics for five years we'll have the
certificate it will all have been
rewired
um because you only need something small
to happen like
i mean if you look over here
i mean these connectors these little
electric connectors
i mean these are old style they're old
style
a little bit of water a little bit of
water going on that
and it's going to be money and i'm
thinking i want this to be done i want
to be done nice
i want to rent well and i want it to be
you know as little
trouble with the property afterwards as
possible one of the great things about
when you do do a buy refurbished finance
property and you and you refurbish it to
a really high new standard
is it's like it's brand new and brand
new houses have much less problems than
old houses
so you really want to fix as much as
possible within reason so lots to think
about when doing a reverb like this
if you enjoyed this video if you enjoy
my channel i'm always going to be
sharing not only the good but also the
warts and all the bad the ugly
and journeying with you and documenting
everything so you can learn
the lessons as i learn them as well so
do me a massive favor if you enjoy my
content
smash like also subscribe to the channel
you can subscribe right below
you can see many future videos in fact
if you want to see how this started
you can watch the video up right here if
you also want to see how we developed
six houses from scratch you can watch
the video right up here
and don't forget to subscribe i look
forward to seeing you next time
peace